chess can often be a long game with more
than 100 moves played but it can also be
incredibly short if you want it to be
many people want to know what are the
fastest checkmates and we are going to
show you but keep in mind
none of these checkmates can be forced
these are only checkmates that you
literally have to try to do on purpose
because they can be otherwise defended
very easily let's see the shortest
possible checkmate on the board white
plays f3 not a great opening move
already exposing the King on the e1 to
h4 diagonal black opens with E 5 notice
the black queen is already looking at
the weakened h4 square ready to pay the
White King a visit white plays g4
further weakening the e1 to h4 diagonal
and the black Queen pounces on the h4
square delivering the fastest checkmate
in chess notice that the white King
cannot move
there's no way to block the check and
you can't capture the checking piece so
after two moves the game is already over
in fact it's time to start a new game
let's see that idea again but this time
it'll be white delivering the checkmate
after E for black plays f6d for g5 and
can you spot the checkmate that's right
Queen h5 the fastest checkmate for white
is in three moves in the fastest
checkmate for black isn't just 2 moves
let's hope that you never find yourself
on the wrong side of this checkmate now
it's your turn to practice the fastest
checkmates